amara the word means power in Swahili it
is also the name of an outreach effort
has begun at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology's computer science and
artificial intelligence laboratory
see sale is an interdepartmental
laboratory that includes faculty from
electrical engineering and computer
science mechanical engineering
mathematics brain and cognitive science
Aeronautics and Astronautics the
biological engineering division and the
harvard-mit division of Health Sciences
and Technology Cecil is also the home of
the World Wide Web Consortium
our goal is to find innovative ways to
enable domestic and international
communities through a combination of
education and technology resources to
which these communities might not
otherwise have access technology by
itself is only a tool a means to an end
but as history has shown access to the
proper tools can fastly improve the
quality of life Amara looks for
opportunities to provide communities
with the tools of computation and
communication and to enrich these with
education MIT and csail provide the
technical expertise logistics and
educational resources behind Amara our
corporate and philanthropic partners
provide funding and equipment to help
meet each community's needs together
with our partners we find innovative
ways to overcome the myriad challenges
of remote and underserved populations
we believe in solving problems that the
community prioritizes all not pushing
Western ideals and values to this end we
work closely with local experts in each
community to understand their needs and
values the underlying philosophy of
Amara is to enable not to just hand out
computers to the poor but to teach them
how to use technology to improve their
lives and then in turn give the gift of
knowledge to other neighboring
communities we help keep the
self-sufficient cycle in motion through
longitudinal outcome studies and learn
from our successes and our failures so
we can continuously improve our efforts
since Amara is a volunteer organization
we are in constant need of computing and
network equipment as well as funding for
administration and travel your
organization can play a role in Amara by
contacting our outreach coordinator at
the email address or phone number shown
on your screen thank you